You see that shit?  It's sunset.
What if-
(Borking)
Okay, so imagine for a second
(more borkings)
Imagine - (borking) - imagine - (borking)
Imagine - (borking)
Imagine, for one second - (borking) - icecream, popsicles.
I. Can't. Even. Comprehend. Rrrrrrrare. Eating. And. Milking.
Ice cream. Popsicle.
People. Only. Purchase. Solid. Ice. Cream. Late. Evening. Sir.
And that's what we have to be doing and what we're gonna be doing is we're gonna put it all in our van
uhh.. vehicle and
Naughty!
We're gonna putting these in our van
And then we're gonna be going out in the evening because it's just hitting dusk right now and we can purchase some stuff
Cruise around town, blast out that typical ice cream truck music
And we're gonna get some purchases.
Oh god damnit.
Okay, uh no.
uhhhhh god
*squeaky squeak*
Ice-cream cone! that works :D
Yeah!
Done! Just like that *scribble*
Ah, that just made it more defined
*let me try, mark*
Much better
*lil smooch*
oH
Oh, it's getting worse *inaudible* it's worse. It's worse. Okay. All right.
Markiplier's Ice Cream Boutique
It'll do
OKAY!
Oh, god, it's everywhere.
First stop, ice cream
I''m gonna call Bob, just in case Bob's got some advice
Hey, shush, shush
Hey!
(Bob: Hey, how's it goin'?) Hey, so we are currently in the process of getting an ice cream truck for the van
And I just wanted your advice on the best way to execute that
Bob: Turning a van into an ice cream truck?
Yeah, yeah because the way I figured, like it's, it's dark out right now, it's getting dark
There aren't any ice cream trucks that run out in the evening, but in evening is when everyone wants dessert
Bob: Sure
Good idea?
Bob: It sounds cool.
Bob: Don't get arrested
Why, why would we?
Bob: I don't... I just feel like there's, this might potentially be creepy, but..
Bob: You got Chica, she sorts of de-creepifies it.
Bob: Lean on Chica for the uncreepy
Okay, all right, anyway, all right. Thank you, all right, se-see ya
Bob: G-go get 'em, buddy
All right, thanks, all right bye.
It's not creepy.
No! It's ice cream, it's fun! For the whole family
At night.
Okay. We gotta go get some stuff, so
You're right! The profits from our last pop-up shop go to the profits for our next ice cream truck. I like it, *squeak* BAM
Chica, excuse me. Whoa privacy please.
I've got Scribblers, ahahaha, rainbow: always fun
Grape, orange, cherry: all classic, and I've got these sweet crunchy drumsticks.
I love me some butter pecan
*strenuous activity from markipoo*
Yeah!!
It beautiful :D
Businesses start out small
They may seem like they're not very much or they're weird or in a creepy van or in a dark scary hallway with a knife
But some businesses start out small and grow into something big
Okay, let's do this
Sir!
Ice cream?
Ma'am!
Unwrap it
Let them see the colour
The colour's really what gets 'em
Someone's honking for ice cream
Yellow!? Why yellow?? That's like the least, alright fine, whatever
Ice cream!!
Ice cream!!!
$200
Y'know, like a- like a sign spinner does. It really gets the attention, you gotta really sell it
Ice cream!
Ice creaam!
You're makin' me hungry for ice cream.  I'm such a good salesman, I'm hungry for ice cream.
That's what they gotta see, they gotta see people eatin' it
MmmmMMMM
MMMmm
It's so good!
Mmmmm!
Alright, fine, fine, fine. That ain't gonna work
We gotta find a place where we can sell ice cream to these people where they need it the most
So, what we have here is a advertising problem. The highway didn't work because-
Not because of us, it's because people didn't know what they were getting, they couldn't really see the experience going on
They couldn't see it, just lusciously getting down my gullet, and that's what people need! So I'm gonna do is we're gonna showcase
Exactly what we got going on here
We got Scribblers...
ah, shit
We got Rainburr (Rainbow)
BAM! Okay, so that's two. They may have 37 flavors
Bunch a bullshit
But we got, we got
Chica, we got Chica. And with Chica. ...She's a biggest selling point that we can ever hope for
Right Chica? What's that light?!
Ah, whatever
uhhh, no!
Kobe! *glass smashing*
We're at a secluded location; a Costco parking lot. It's closed, but we don't care about that
They won't be our competitor for now. But, we do you need to get customers, so I'm gonna tell people that we're here
And it's gonna be totally chill.
The mistake I made last time is I didn't emphasize that it was a 'happy, friendly experience', so I'm gonna say
Markiplier's
Friendly Ice Cream Truck
Come get your iced creams
*mumbling* Ice cream truck is open for business
You want some ice cream?
What we need... is some swweeeet music
*odd, 8-bit sounding tune*
I mean the image is right, but I don't know if that's... that doesn't feel right
*pop/R&B-ish mix* *Chica panting*
No
*classic ice cream truck tunes*
Nothing friendlier. Now we just wait for the customers to roll in
Oh! I almost forgot! Hang on- wait!
We're not ready, we're not ready, I forgot
I didn't put the other, uh, flavours up on the thing
Customer: Hi, we were just driving by
Wow
customers right here with the ice cream truck, pulls everybody here
Just give us two, two minutes.
*muffled* I just wanna advertise all the flavours
Almost ready, almost ready. Hang on- two seconds!
Ah, jeez *tape sounds* Okay
all right, um...
Welcome!
To, uh, Markiplier's Friendly Ice Cream Truck. What, uh? What would you like?
Customer: I'll take a rainbow one please
A Rainbow! What flavour of Rainbow?
I need the music going, hang on, we really gotta pump up the ambiance here.
Okay, alright, enough goofing around here. Do I have to do all the work here? Thank you.
How 'bout a, a- a... purp- a bluuue
Girl: Thank you
What would you like?
Boy: That's fine
Okay cool, there you gooo. That'll be $50
Girl: Oh shii- ...um...
um... um...
Okay, so they ran off, but that's not bad because they'll be
uh... uh...
It's good for business, just forget about it's good for business
We got all the advertising, we got the music ready to go when it's going we got the ice cream
uh... You got anything else?
Why do you still have those?
If there's one person that knows exactly what goes on in the business strategy. It's Tyler. He is a masters in sports- Hello!
Tyler, are you there?
Tyler: Is it working now?
Yeah, okay. Hey, how's it going? Okay? So we have an ice cream truck
I just want to run a few things by you you tell me if it's a good idea or bad idea
We got, our ice cream in our ice bucket. We've got the jammin' tunes right there. They're not playing right now
Let me see if I can
Where is the music... We got- wait! ah! We got a customer! There it is
hang on
Hang on, hold on. Wait, why, Tyler are you there? We're open for business. Where's your face? Hello good customer!
Customer: Sup?
Come on down!
Customer: I'm comin' up now
Hello!
You can see all of our flavours
Sweater Guy: Is she available for sale?
NO!
What flavor would you like?
Hat Person: Oh, well I didn't think of the ice cream part
We said an ice cream truck!
Sweater Guy: A drumstick over here.
Drumstick...
Hat Person: I'm feeling a cherry popsicle
Okay, all right, you get him the cherry popsicle. I'll get the drumsticks. Okay be right there
Alright, Tyler we gotta go, we got customers. See ya!
Hat Person: Do I get two? For the price of nothing?
What? No! They're- they're $50.
Hat Person: um, sorry 'bout that
You didn't even pay! You think you can run?!
He's quick. He's real quick. Ok, what do you want?
Red Hair: Drumstick
Drumstick! We're gonna run outta Drumsticks.
Don't you show your face around here again
Hat Person: I'll just keep my distance
You better.
Welcome, welcome, okay, who wants some ice cream?
Purple Guy: Yeah, let's do some ice cream. What do we got?
Uh, it's right there?
Purple Guy: Oh... my reading comprehensions not there.
You don't even have to read! This is colours and shapes!
Purple Guy: I'll take a Drumstick.
Why does everybody want a Drumstick?!
We did not- we've got butter pecan ice cream as well in a tub
Purple Guy: I'll do- I'll do the tub cream
Get the tub cream
Purple Guy: It is... It is literally just a tub
Don't worry, it's nice and soft
Purple Guy: D-do I go for it?
Yeah
Purple Guy: Alright, we got it
Alright that'll be $50
Purple Guy: Deal.
Purple Guy: You want it liquid or card?
Why is your cash liquid?
Purple Guy: Because I can't grab it like this and have it be dry
That's fift- you- Pay!
What do you want?
Happy Fighter: A Crayon!
It says 'Scribbler'
Right there
Happy Fighter: Woah it's two Crayons!
What would you like?
Late Arrival: Uhh... Scribbler
A Scrib- Thaaank you
Happy Fighter: It's a Crayon!
There you go, that'll be $100
Late Arrival: Excuse you? No.
Okay alright, thank you guys so much for not paying any money!
See ya
All right, we are sold out of ice cream again
but unfortunately
We didn't make a goddamn penny because nobody paid anything for what they were supposed to get
ehh, either way it was fun
I think we got the word out, we can write that all off as advertising
In people's minds when they think of ice cream they think of me
But anyway, thanks so much for all the help as usual, that was really fun
Let me know what you think, uh, what we should do in the future and..
Thanks again, and as always. I'll see you in the next one bye bye!